foreign
I welcome all who stand for common
efforts and I promise
being really united we can guarantee
Fair peace for all nations
what's more Unity can prevent Wars
ladies and gentlemen
Mr Secretary General Mr President fellow
leaders
this call so many many words but not as
active Defender against the aggressions
in many cases the fear War the final war
was the loudest year
the war after which no one would Gather
in the General Assembly Hall again
the sword world war was seen as a
nuclear war a conflict between states on
the highway to nukes
other Wars seemed less scary compared to
a threat of the so-called great Powers
firing their nuclear
stockpiles
show their 20th century taught the world
to restrain from the use of the weapons
of mass
destruction not to deploy
not to proliferate not to threaten with
and not to test but to promote a
complete nuclear disarmament
frankly
this is a good strategy but
but it should not be the only strategy
to protect the world from the final war
Ukraine gave up its third largest
nuclear Arsenal the world then decided
Russia should become a keeper of such
power
yet history shows it was Russia who
deserved nuclear disarmament the most
back in 1990s
and Russia deserves it now terrorists
have no right to hold nuclear weapons no
right
but truly not the nukes are the scariest
now
while New York's remain in place the
mass destruction is gaining its momentum
the aggressor is weaponizing many other
things and those things are used not
only against our country but against all
of yours as well
fellow leaders there are many
conventions that restrict weapons but
there are no real restrictions on
weaponization
first let me let me give you an example
the food
since the start of the full-scale war
the Ukrainian ports in the black and as
of seas have been blocked by Russia
until now our boards on the Danube River
Remain the target for missiles and
drones
and it is a clear Russia's attempt to
weaponize the food shortage on the
global market in exchange for
recognition for some if not all of the
captured territories
Russia is launching the food prices as
weapons
the impact spans from the Atlantic coast
of Africa to the southeast Asia and this
is the threat scale and I would like to
thank those leaders who supported our
Black Sea grain initiative and program
Green from Ukraine thank you so much
[Applause]
united united we made weapons turned
back into food again more than 45
Nations saw how important it is to make
Ukrainian food products available on the
market from Algeria to Spain
to Indonesia and China
and even now when Russia has undermined
the Black Sea grain initiative we are
working to ensure food stability and I
hope that many of you will join us in
these efforts we launched
a temporary sea expert corridor from our
pores and we are working hard to
preserve the land roots for grain
exports
and it is alarming to see how some in
Europe some our friends in Europe play
out solidarity in political theater
making Thriller from the green and they
may seem to play their own role but in
fact they are helping helping set the
stage to a Moscow actor
second
weaponization of energy
many times the world has witnessed
Russia using energy as a weapon Kremlin
weaponized oil and gas to weaken the
leaders of other countries when they
came to the red square and now now this
threat is even greater Russia is
weaponizing nuclear energy not only it
is not only it is spreading its
unreliable nuclear power plant
Construction Technologies but it is also
turning other countries power plants
into real dirty bombs
power plant
shelled it occupied it and now
blackmails others with radiation leaks
is there any sense to reduce nuclear
weapons when Russia is weaponizing
nuclear power plants
scary question
the Global Security architecture offers
no response or protection against such a
treacherous radiation threat and there
is no accountability for radiation
blackmailers so far
the sword example is children
unfortunately in various terrorist
groups abduct children to put pressure
on their families and societies but
never before the mass kidnapping and
deportation would become a part of the
government policy not until now
we know the names of tens of thousands
of children
and have evidence on hundreds of
thousands of others kidnapped by Russia
in the occupied territories of Ukraine
and later deported
the international
Criminal Court
issued a rest warrant for Putin
for this crime
and we are trying to get children back
home
but time time goes by what will happen
with them what will happen to them
those children in Russia are taught to
hate Ukraine and all ties with their
families are broken and this is clearly
a genocide
when hatred is weaponized Against One
Nation it never stops there
Each decade
Russia starts a new war
parts of moldovan Georgia remain
occupied Russia turns Syria into ruins
and if not Russia the chemical weapons
would have never been used there in
Syria
Russian has almost swallowed Belarus it
is obviously a threatening Kazakhstan
and other Baltic states
and the goal of them present war against
Ukraine is to tour Our Land
our people our lives our resources into
a weapon against you again the
international
rules-based order
many seats in the General Assembly Hall
may become empty
empty if Russia succeeds with its
treachery and aggression
lettuce and gentlemen
the aggressor
scatters deaths and brings ruins even
without nukes but the outcomes are alike
we see towns
with the villages in Ukraine wiped out
by Russian Artillery leveled to the
ground completely we see the war of
drones we know the possible effects of
spreading the war into the cyberspace
the artificial intelligence could be
trained to combat well before it would
long to help the humanity
thank God
people have not yet learned to use
climate as a weapon
even though humanity is failing on its
climate policy objectives this means
that extreme weather will still impact
the normal Global Life and some evil
state will also verbalize its outcomes
and when people in the streets of New
York
and other cities of the world went out
on climate protest we all have seen them
and when people in Morocco and Libya and
other countries die as a result of
natural disasters
and when islands and countries disappear
underwater and when tornadoes and
deserts are spreading into into new
territories and when all of this is
happening one unnatural disaster in
Moscow decided to launch a big war and
kill tens of thousands of people
[Music]
we have to stop it
we must act
United to defeat the aggressor and focus
all our capabilities and energy on
addressing these challenges
as nukes are restrained
likewise the aggressor must be
restrained and all its tools and message
a war
each word now can become final but it
takes our Unity to make sure that
aggression will not breaking again
and it is not a dialogue between the
so-called great power somewhere behind
the closed doors that can guarantee us
all the new Wars era but open War of all
Nations for peace
[Music]
last year I presented the outlines of
the Ukrainian peace formula at the U.N
General Assembly later in Indonesia I
presented the full formula and over the
past year the peace formula became the
basis to update the existing security
architecture now we can bring now we can
bring back to life the U.N Charter and
guarantee the full power for the
rules-based world order
and tomorrow I will present the details
at a special meeting of the U.N security
Council the main thing is that it is not
only about Ukraine
more than
140 stage and international
organizations have supported the
Ukrainian peace formula fully or in part
the Ukrainian peace formula is becoming
Global its points offer Solutions and
steps that will stop all forms of
weaponization that Russia used against
Ukraine and other countries and maybe
used by other aggressors
look for the first time in modern
history we have a real chance to end the
aggression on the terms of the nation
which was attacked
and this is a real chance for every
nation to ensure that aggression against
against your state if it happens God
forbid will and not because your land
will be divided and you will be forced
to submit to military or political
pressure but because your territory and
sovereignty will be fully restorted
we launched the format of meetings
between National Security advisors and
diplomatic Representatives important
talks and consultations were held in
Hiroshima in Copenhagen and in Jeddah on
the implementation of the peace formula
and we are preparing Global Peace Summit
and please I invite all of you all of
you who do not tolerate any aggression
to jointly prepare the assignment and I
am aware of the attempts to make some
shady dealings behind their scenes evil
cannot be trusted
ask pregosian if one bets on Putin's
promises
please hear me let Unity decide
everything openly while Russia is
pushing the world to the final war
Ukraine is doing everything to ensure
that after Russian aggression no one in
the world will dare to attack Any Nation
we organization must be restrained war
crimes must be punished deported people
must come back home and the occupier
must return to their own land we must be
United to make it and we'll do it
foreign